[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
hello love kathy all right yeah fine are
you
that's spot on
clothes
you are sorry
sarah's waiting there
[Laughter]
aren't you allowed in there now lee
[Laughter]
no i'm not wondering
hello could someone in the chamber speak
we're having a few problems here
yes we can i think so just bear with me
okay uh nikki can you forward charlotte
some papers please
we're struggling on mod.gov at the
moment i think yeah of course is it just
uh counselor cupid or does anybody else
need them as well does anyone else need
papers
no everyone else seems to have them
okay i'll they'll be with her in a
moment thanks
paul sorry i missed your call i was just
animated
don't move quick enough to respond
yeah if we can have a chat later you
know
uh that will be great thank you i'll
give you a ring on the way back that's
fine
apologies for not being in the
in the room this this afternoon i had a
business meeting that ran up against
this one
so
i had to
had to dial in remotely
[Music]
hi mark
hi everyone hi alex
okay it's
4 30 now do i need to do anything to
wait for us to record or has it already
been recorded
um
so uh we can we can start the live feed
when you're already then
is that to say that it's live feed
started yes the live feed has started
okay lovely thank you um welcome
everyone it's the meeting of the cabinet
of north east alberta district council
um i'm councillor alex dale i'm the
leader of the council and with me in the
chamber we have councillor cupid who's
deputy leader
councillor powell councillor kenyon and
councillor
renick who are all cabinet members
we have jane dethick our finance officer
sarah sternberg our monitoring officer
and lee hicken our managing director and
matt broughton
one of our directors
and on screen we have
various officers kath rory uh alan marr
nicky carver as well as council mark
foster and councillor paul parkin who
will be
participating in the meeting but not
voting because they're not here
uh present in the in the room
okay uh we'll start with the agenda
which is the first item's apologies for
absence i don't believe we've had any
have we non-received yeah
thank you um and then any declarations
of interest from any members
okay obviously okay
okay thank you
um the next item is minutes to last
meeting
um i'll happily move them do i have a
second
yeah cancer keep it all those in favor
okay okay
um who's taking that paper is it me
okay
sorry um
no we thought that we were gonna have uh
some of the scrutiny committee chairs
here and there seemed to be some
difficulties on that
so i don't you want to take it or
whether mrs sternberg wants to make any
comments
mrs sternberg
uh yes sorry we've got nobody here to
present this but this is just their
program for your information
thanks mr sternberg uh i'm happy to uh
support the the program i think we've
all um we've all seen it before and and
and
happy that the the scrutiny committees
uh continue on that basis so i'll i'll
move it have a second
council run it thank you all those in
favor
okay that's carried thank you
uh so the next item
back to the agenda is the uh action plan
for business center and industrial unit
scrutiny review um so this is a response
to a previous scrutiny review and i'll
hand over to councillor renick to talk
us through this one
yes thank you i think this is the
as the
chair of the scrutiny the industrial
units original paper from april 2019
came to me from the previous
administration and it was an interesting
reader but i think i recommended at that
time that perhaps a bit more work could
be done on it so some more work has been
done we i think we accepted
last cabin at the street review part two
and this is the response the action plan
the business centers and industrial
units
and so i i i'm really pleased with this
piece of work i think it
highlighted for the issues that we'd
raised originally
um
i've been to all the business centres
industrial units and there's a wider
piece of work going on around our assets
portfolio so there might be more to come
but i think this is a good interim
measure
at picking up some of the
issues i think we can resolve fairly
easily
and um i
happen to recommend the actual plan
which is attached to the
appendix brilliant thanks very much
council right i'll happily second do you
have any comments
no okay all those in favor
thank you that's carried
um so the next item is the single
equality scheme uh year two review i'm
not sure whether whether council foster
is taking this or or
oh yeah over to you mark
thanks chair
this report is the year two review of
the single equality scheme 2019
to 2023
and notes to work in progress made by
the council
in appendix one the three deuters the
council as per the equality act 2010 are
set out
they are eliminating discrimination and
victimization
advancing equality of opportunity
fostering good relations
the act also has a requirement for local
authorities to set specific objectives
our equality objectives are set out in
2.3 of the report they are
everyone can access our services
facilities and information
decision making and services take into
account the needs of residents and
communities
discrimination harassment and hate crime
is not to be tolerated
and lastly our workforce and workforce
policies support equality
uh overall it's a it's a good news story
there's been some good work done by our
officers and some good progress made so
thank you to the officers for that
other than that unless we've got any
questions
i'm grateful that mrs drury is here to
answer any detailed questions because
she knows much more about it than i do
but other than that the recommendations
are to note the report
thanks mark um cath have you got
anything you want to add
only to say just to uh to it however
councillor foster said i think it's it's
fair to say that equality is at
northeast is really well embedded
it's not something that we just add on
as an extra it's part of our process
whether we're delivering services or
thinking of new policies and new ways of
working i think that's helped by having
a central team that people go to for
advice and that's why it's been
relatively easy for my team to put this
annual review document together because
we know where the evidence is and we're
party to a lot of that so it's it's good
that we do the annual review and it's
obviously part of the legislation that
we publish this information
but it's just nice to reassure members
and also obviously our residents that
it's it's well in hand
brilliant thanks kath and thanks for all
the the work on that and to both you and
council foster um i think we probably
need to set a rule for whether we're
going to use formal titles or uh or
first names together because keep going
back and forth but anyway
um
i'll happily propose that paper uh
councillor uh kenyon is gonna second all
those in favor
thank you that's carried
um and then the next item is the medium
term financial plan uh monitoring report
so i'll hand over to councillor parking
for this one
thank you very much chair um and uh
this is the uh budget monitoring april
to september just can i just do an audio
check are we okay can you hear me okay
yeah we're gonna be fine
okay so uh the purpose of this report is
to update cabinet on the financial
position of the council at quarter two
uh now i'm not going to go through this
in detail simply because the next report
uh addresses uh although any of those
things that have come up in this q2
budget monitoring so uh if it's okay
with you i'll just briefly mention the
treasury management
appendix five as this doesn't form parts
of the revised budget uh and essentially
that's business as usual there's no
matters arising to report and then on
our half hour uh sorry half yearly
update half hour that would be uh
frequent half yearly update will be
presented to council um on monday so
happy to take any questions if there are
any uh and if not then if somebody in
the room could move it move the
recommendation to note that will be
great
okay thanks councillor parking i'm happy
to uh move the recommendation that we
note uh the report do you have a second
uh councillor uh
uh all those in favor
thank you that's carried
uh so then the next item is the uh
revised budgets paper so i'll hang back
over to you council parking thank you
thank you chair and yeah this report
presents
the uh
revisions to the
2021-22 budget uh which was presented to
council in february and approved by
council in february once we've
considered these revisions here today
i'll be asking cabinet to recommend that
they'll be approved by council as part
of the budget setting process in january
so i'll start by outlining the position
of the general fund
and uh it's it's pretty much as you'd
expect covet is still impacting on our
budgets but it's really really
pleasing to note that our football to
the leisure centers is improving week by
week which is helping our financial
position a lot
uh these budgets include um the central
government sales fees and charges claim
for losses
for the first quarter of
around 300 thousand pounds
um the
rest of the ongoing covered related
spend ie that's on ict ppe
etc is being covered from the kovic
grant so won't actually affect our
budget
and you'll recall in that in july
council approved the additional
expenditure required to run the waste
recycling service in-house following the
collapse
of our external provider
and the 465k
growth has been built into the budget
so uh on the report
and sorry just need to move something
on on the report on to the report table
two shows the main variances identified
with further analysis of 1.6 and 1.7
expenditure funded from reserves and
income from grants as a result of covet
is still playing a big part in the
budget this year um
lots of swings and roundabouts with uh
with with uh where that uh when those
funds come in and when they go out
uh and
another unexpected growth item uh is the
uh
1.75
pay award that was uh awarded to public
sector workers when setting the budgets
last year we we actually expected that
to be around one percent
um
uh but instead we've had to absorb a
further uh three-quarter percent uh in
into that uh
into that budget so um the efficient the
efficiencies identified through this
revised budget process of being
sufficient to fund growth such as the
additional cost of the bay award but
they're not sufficient to fund the
increased cost of the waste recycling
so it's been funded in this budget from
the resilience reserve and the savings
identified during the remainder of the
year
will be used to pay this back
so whilst the resilience reserve was
created for just this kind of
eventuality um you know you can only
spend that money once as it were using
reserves is not sustainable long term
so this is being considered as part of
the budget setting for next year and of
course the mtfp refresh
so talking about the hra
and
i don't propose to go into a lot of the
well there isn't a lot of revisions to
be honest as as they're minimal they're
set out in appendix 3
for you to consider
and finally the capital programme and um
other than accounting for budget
rollovers from last year which cabinet
approved in july there are no changes uh
to the
to the uh
hra program the general fund has been
increased to reflect the approval of the
additional 990 k for killer marsh
leisure center
which we're looking forward to being
open
and more and increasing football again
and the first transit funding for the
clay cross town works uh 1.2 million so
happy to take any questions at this
point
um and again if somebody could move it
in the room that would be very good
thanks uh councillor parking any
questions from anyone
oh okay i'm happy to move it obviously
um
as you pointed out the key change in all
this is the
um
move to bring the the recycling
contractor in-house which is an
eventuality that we couldn't
uh you know we didn't actually actively
seek out but obviously had to have to
act and did so
uh very well and you know with minimal
uh interruption or disruption for uh for
residents and obviously protected jobs
in doing so so
um clearly it was a positive thing to do
but it does have a budget impact and we
have to um to to you know be careful
moving forward around how we how we
mitigate that um but yeah as i say i'm
happy to uh happy to
propose do we have a second
at council kenyan thank you
all those in favor
thank you that's carried
and then moving back to the agenda the
next item is the the council's housing
company so i'll hand over to councillor
powell just to talk through this
[Music]
and since then a lot has happened um
situations have changed
and they've remained
very dormant ever since
with the new management degree we've
changed the way
we've clarified the way we deal
[Music]
achieving um objectives
um and we've also created an investment
model
which basically
does the job
so with alternative structures in
[Music]
casa powell's microphone on the remote
feed is struggling to hear his phone i
start again
i'm never so sorry if i if i was reading
from the script i would say accurately
again but i'm not so um
can i just say again then that um a
number of years ago we set up these
companies and in anticipation of a
number of things which
haven't come to fruition
and so they've been dormant um
we have set up alternative ways of
dealing with all the issues that were
connected with them
um and including the management
agreement which uh which has just been
put into place
so on that basis we don't actually need
these extra add-on companies
um and i need to make it clear that
richmond homes itself of course remains
entirely intact and there is no
difference whatsoever in that
relationship and partnership we have
with them i think we should make that
absolutely clear
so on that basis uh chair i'd like to
recommend that we wind up uh the
companies mentioned in the report
thank you ken for powell i'm uh i'm
happy to second i didn't have the heart
to tell you your microphone was off so i
was just going to repeat everything you
said when i
when i came in
it was too late by the time by the time
i noticed myself
anyway um yeah i'm happy to second i
think for all the reasons you've
outlined the the companies were set up
at a different time when obviously we've
been through
uh quite a few changes not at least the
code pandemic and there's different ways
of achieving
the same result obviously so um so it
doesn't make sense to continue with them
um so i'm happy to second uh any of the
comments from anyone
no all those in favor
okay thank you that's carried
uh and then the next item is
get back to the right screen
uh the eckington depot refurbishment so
i'll hand over to kenneth kenyon just to
talk through this one
thank you chair
yes i feel a little bit guilty because
we've had lots of
discussion about uh finance over
the last few months really and uh with
covid and it does seem like lots of
things have fallen on our watch um
we forgot to mention kill nice sports
center earlier on as well as something
that was
um
rescuing a sports center is is a big
deal to take into the council and this
unfortunately is one more which is the
depot
which is used for street scene and also
as an mot center
it's been running on a shoestring for a
long time really it's uh
if anybody visits the site you you'll
appreciate how
old and unloved it appears to be and
everything's come together with a mix of
flood damage that we've had in recent
years requiring works on flood
prevention
we've had a fire risk
assessment which generated
uh initially 100 odd thousand pounds of
work and then that expanded even further
and the third thing is the welfare
facilities for quite a lot of staff who
are going out there in all weathers to
to empty our bins and grit our roads uh
are woefully inadequate plus we've had
the additional pressure of the
taking the red bin service in-house um
which is you know more people again
and we've
got the point where all of that's
accumulated into a necessary package of
work
of 525 000 pounds
which would uh require
um
the capital program to be increased to
fund that
and so
um what i would ask is people would
accept the recommendations in the report
to approve the works and approve the
increase in the capital fund to fund
those works
okay
thanks councillor kenyon i'll hand over
to council cupid now let's go
um yeah just to i'd like to second uh
this paper cancer kenyan uh and just to
reiterate my full support for it as
cabinet member for street scene um i
think what counselor kenyon said about
the staff members down there the
difficult job that they do and have
continued to do through covid it's
important to invest in the facility
and we have you know carefully
considered costs over the last few
months and other you know any other
options that could be available
but given the service that we're
providing and the difficulties of sort
of changing that i think the depot
presents the best value for money so
fully support this
positive improvement
brilliant thanks very much any other
comments or questions uh council running
yeah just to say to council colleen
don't apologize hey this is staff
welfare um b it's it's a duty for us to
look after assets and i i do think
that might have slipped over the over
the years before we took over and yes it
comes back to us now to repair assets
that you know if you don't keep up with
the maintenance of properties and assets
then you're clobbered with a large
amount which is what we're finding
ourselves in the position of now so i
wouldn't apologize neither counts i
think what we're doing is the right
thing
thank you councillor
absolutely agree completely um okay so
we've got a mover and a seconder
all those in favor
okay that's carrie thank you very much
the next item is urgent items of which
there are none
so i moved to exclude the public so i
move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during the discussion of the
following items of business to avoid the
disclosure to them of exempt information
as defined in part one of schedule 12a
to the local government at 1972.
um
okay if we can just end the
live recording and
um okay
you